hi
it's one of my
main insecurities and it has been for a
long time i just hide it well
hello
hi hi angela
so nice to meet you how are you doing
well thank you dr matasaro
it's a pleasure
i'm just
what did you say
so what brings you in today well now i'm
kind of embarrassed to tell you the way
you look like i'm expecting an old
doctor
don't be embarrassed at all when i was
18 i had an accident where two of my
teeth got knocked out
and then as years progressed not take
smoking
you know menopause coming on my teeth
started breaking and then i had teeth
down here and from this i i don't know
what it's called deteriorating of the
gum
loosen my two teeth down here so one
come out and the other one from just
eating away the gum the other one come
out before you knew it from smoking they
were loose
i see
my husband doesn't know this you've
described a lot of you know serious
dental issues that you're having inside
your mouth how is it that your husband
you know isn't aware of these serious
issues
first of all my husband's in nigeria oh
that's far away yeah so i'm trying to do
this all because we're waiting on our
spousal visa okay
so what is it that you're hoping i can
do for you
i really want implants but
it's a possibility that i can get those
so that's why you're here so that we can
determine if you are a candidate i got
faith in your dog
not taking care of these
false teeth earlier or the little
dentures that i have added on and not
take care of my own mouth i'm losing
bone and bone is very crucial for
implants
relax your lip please perfect
and i'm gonna tell you this procedure
i'm hoping to get is the most important
one ever if i had a choice i would have
done this procedure before this
procedure
so you know you're missing a lot of
teeth yep right um the teeth that you do
have you see all this brown hair
you're having a lot of dental decay on
your remaining teeth
and you're also having a lot of what we
call periodontal disease yes so the the
structure that holds the teeth into your
jaw is actually deteriorating
really
oh
you have to have bone to have implants
and um that's my major fear that i don't
have no bone
[Music]